catherine bros maître de conférences à
l'université et gustave eiffel
spécialiste des questions du
développement de landes
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur un rt france une explosion des
quarts des contaminations qui ont plus
que doublé depuis le début du mois la
situation semble hors de contrôle en
inde
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer ça
est-ce que et qu'elle est aussi la
situation dans les hôpitaux al
effectivement la situation est très très
compliqué alors s'explique par deux deux
phénomènes principaux le premier c'est
l'émergence d'un variant qui du virus
qui a doublement m'étais et donc qui
paraît beaucoup plus contagieux et le
deuxième c'est effectivement un
relâchement des gestes barrières avec
l'autorisation de grands rassemblements
religieux est aussi politique qui ont eu
lieu à travers du pays des matches de
cricket en fait d'aider des
rassemblements de population qui sont
propices à la à une contamination rapide
donc c'est principalement les deux les
deux facteurs et au niveau des hôpitaux
évidemment ils sont énormément sous
tension et ça se passe pas très bien
puisque effectivement vous avez dit 200
mille nouveaux cas par jour c'est énorme
et c'est bien plus que la première vague
en fait à séoul au coeur de la première
vague il y avait à peu près 80 mille cas
donc là c'est beaucoup plus important et
c'est vrai que ça c'est en ça c'est en
bocaux pays vous dirais qu'il ya un déni
de la gravité de la situation de la part
des autorités vous vous évoquez une
raison politique
au fait que notamment les fêtes
religieuses se soient maintenus alors
est ce que c'est une décision politique
c'est plutôt la confusion du message
politique en fait c'est à dire que les
mesures de restriction sont envoyés au
niveau des états puisque l'un dernier
fédéral donc là effectivement chaque
état a pris ces mesures a pris des
mesures de pour restreindre la
contamination
l'épicentre étant maharashtra donc là il
ya beaucoup de défauts de restrictions
qui sont imposées au niveau du
maharashtra qui est l'état dans lequel
se trouve bombay mumbai
par contre le message est extrêmement
créé beaucoup de confusion en inde
puisque à la fois vous avez des enfants
qui sont qui ont pas été à l'école
depuis un an des restrictions qui sont
imposés en même temps il ya au bengale
des élections qui ont lieu avec des
meetings politiques avec plus de cent
mille personnes
vous avez aussi second festival
religieux hindou lacombe et l'inquiéter
or organisé qui était autorisé des
matches de crickets alors c'est pas du
tout un épiphénomène en inde dans les
matches de crickets sahara sont beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de gens donc à une
espèce de confusion sur ce qu'il
convient de faire puisqu'à la fois la
vague déferle est à la fois il ya des
mesures de barrières qui sont pas du
tout respecté en fait à moi aussi de la
campagne de vaccination dans le pays
comment est-ce que vous la qualifieriez
ce qu'elle est trop lente on rappelle
que le pays est peuplé de 1,3 milliard
d'habitants a payé extrêmement pauvres
oui alors la campagne de vaccination se
déroule est ce qu'elle est lente ou
rapide c'est difficile à dire par contre
là aussi ce qui est clair c'est qu'il ya
de la confusion qui règne puisque en
fait les gares jusqu'à présent
d'emblaver dit aujourd'hui hier et à
l'autorisation du vaccin russ springer
qui a été approuvé en urgence de la même
manière en fait
avant il y avait deux vaccins qui était
autorisée il y avait le vaccin au soir
d'astrazeneca et un vaccin
produit par une entreprise indienne est
en fait ce vaccin pareil énormément de
confusion et de doutes sur ce vaccin
puisque en fait les résultats de la
phase iii ne sont pas disponibles
les résultats de la phase ii sont
arrivés des tests face enfin la phase ii
des tests sont arrivés alors que le
médecin était déjà largement administrés
donc en fait et beaucoup de suspicion
sur ce vaccin ce qui a créé beaucoup de
confusion et ce vaccin donc locale qui
s'appelle kovacs in avait été pareil a
approuvé en urgence le lendemain de
déclarations des uns et nous manque
beaucoup de de résultats on n'a pas
forcément de test et le lendemain ils
étaient appelés en urgence par les
autorités donc au niveau de la campagne
de vaccination elle se déroule elle se
déploie c'est sûr qu'il ya quand même
depuis janvier il ya 10 millions de
doses qui ont quand même été
administrées mais c'est sûr que du point
de vue de la population en fait il ya
une vraie confusion c'est à dire qui et
quel vaccin est fiable pas fiable
comment s'y prendre etc etc
merci beaucoup pour votre réaction sur
rt france catherine bros maître de
conférences à l'université et gustave
eiffel et spécialiste des questions du
développement de la honda